[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh mackenzie milton fuller state
quarterback had uh quite a weekend even
though florida state lost that game in
overtime to notre dame and sort of the
back story we had him on the show
three years ago
he was at central florida
and uh you know he was there with scott
frost and this was that that great
resurgence with that program and he was
electric uh quarterback out of uh hawaii
and uh then he got injured devastating
injury
and uh they thought at some point they
were gonna they might have to amputate
his right leg and then he had surgery
after surgery seven surgeries there was
an infection in there
and uh
i just thought you know what he's
probably going to be a coach somewhere
and all of a sudden this ghost appeared
reappeared on the sidelines with florida
state and i go oh my gosh mackenzie
milton is on the sidelines there
with uh florida state but
uh he joins us now you know i know it's
been a long journey but
let me let me go back to
jordan travis's helmet comes off in the
game and then you go in
but when you go in do you think you're
in there for longer than one play
i i truly didn't know um i didn't know
what you know the coach's thought
process was in that situation
um but you know we went in there called
a pass play a little smash concept and
you know i threw the corner out
after we had a big play figure you know
i'd stay in because usually we'd like to
go tempo after we get a first down so um
you know i just stayed in there and you
know roll with it
and then momentum energy you get
adrenaline going how important was that
for you and did at any point you think
about your knee your leg um
yeah i think you know always getting
that first completion and always getting
that first first down is important
anytime you're trying to get into rhythm
so
i think that was big to you know hit
that first route to jakai and um just
get the sticks moving
and then you know i think the first time
i got tackled uh you know i kind of got
bent up a little and
obviously i felt like them tackle on my
leg but you know i felt fine i didn't
feel anything twins i didn't feel
anything like
uncomfortable so you know i felt good
out there felt
felt good running cutting sliding um
it was a lot of fun a lot of fun to be
back out there
do you realize how tough it was on your
parents watching
yeah i know my mom was um
i'm a mom she don't really want me
playing football you know she's um
she wants me to get into coaching
already but
i think you can only
you can only truly understand you know
if you go through it and you know you
play this game and you love this game to
to come back from something like i did
and that's really any injury um any
tough injury that you go through
kind of takes a twisted individual that
you know likes to go through pain and
likes to
just loves this game so much they'll put
they'll put their body to
extremely tough things to to play this
game at a high level
how many times did you say i can't do it
don't think i ever said i can't do it i
there's definitely times i said i don't
know if i can do this
just in terms of um
whether it be out at practice and you
know my leg would just be
killing me like a 10 out of 10 pain
or just days that i didn't feel like
doing it but
you know i had
great teammates great people pushing me
through my rehab um
you know obviously you got to have some
internal motivation but having those
people around you that those right
support systems makes all the difference
and you know that's what i've had
my time at ucf to my time here
just everybody pushing me to
to help me reach my goals that i set for
myself now is to play football game what
was the worst day you had
definitely you know getting my infection
um
because i was progressing to a point
where i probably
i probably would have been on track to
you know be back on the football field
and really in 2020 um
like playing at a right playing at that
point but
you know it was
about four months out my initial like
reconstruction surgery my range of
motion was great i was back in the
weight room doing things
way ahead of schedule and then i got an
infection which resulted in like four
more surgeries
um
so that was the hardest day and just the
hardest process just like basically
start starting from square one one in
rehab and
in terms of getting flexion on my knee
and just
just basically setting me back 18 months
really to to get back to where i wanted
to get to but
you know just one of those things you
know like throws you some curve balls
sometimes and you know i had to
sit in that batter's box and you know
wait wait on the right pitch and you
know here i am uh
september 5th 2021 was the day that that
was meant for me to step back out there
and i felt great doing it
did you ever talk to alex smith
alex texted me um
i think when i got cleared to start
practicing um last year
and that was really cool just being able
to watch him last year
go through and
you know he he he probably had it worse
than me with what he went through so
just seeing him come back seeing guys
like jalen smith guys like teddy
bridgewater um
obviously you know some of theirs
weren't to the extent of probably alex
and i but they still went through it you
know what i mean they went through that
rehab they went through what they had to
and got the plan out of elite levels so
seeing guys like that
just gave me all the motivation in the
road that i could do something of that
nature
when you go back to the injury
did you realize what did you realize at
the time
i knew it was bad i knew it was bad just
seeing my leg dangling like that i knew
it wasn't like a normal acl or anything
like that um
[Music]
obviously having a rush to the hospital
kind of gives you some concerns and
stuff like that and waking up with you
know external fixator metal bars
two three feet sticking out of your leg
is just like
it's humbling you know what i mean
having to go from
you know really feeling like you're the
best
best player at any any game on the field
to not being able to walk for
an extended amount of time really like
six months and
you know that's that's just a humbling
feeling it puts things into perspective
and then
when you get back to the point where i'm
at being able to run jump cut and play
play the game you love again it
makes it all more sweet
we're talking to mac milton and uh you
got
jacksonville state this weekend who's
starting
i'm not sure
that's that's a that's a question for
the head ball coach my uh
my nil earnings that's out of my pay
grade
you're turning 24 in october
how much grief do you get from your uh
18 19 year old teammates
man too much too much
they're all they're on my butt all the
time like what was this your eighth
tenth year of college
it's all good fun man i love being in
locker room i love
i love i love being around the guys it's
it's
there's nothing like it
you're gonna be a coach when you're done
yes sir that's the plan that's the plan
are you gonna stay at florida state
i'm not sure wherever the opportunities
present themselves you know i feel like
you know i've made some great
connections and have i've had great
insight from you know coach norbell to
coach frost to coach hypo so
um learn from great offensive minds and
i feel like the tools i learned from
them will equip me wherever i go
see the problem with you coaching though
mac is whenever you have an injury
then they're gonna like they can't get
any sympathy from you
well i
it's hard for me to feel sorry for
people like when they get hurt you know
i like i have empathy for them going
through that that rehab process
but to me it's a mindset and how you and
how you attack it so um
i whenever my guys whenever my teammates
go through it i'm always there you know
trying to pick them up and support them
but you know that's the cars that they
were dealt and that's the cars that i
was dealt so everybody's got their
battles to fight and you know i had mine
and you know we got some guys going
through some things right now so
to me when i'm a coach i'm gonna support
them through and through just like my
coaches did me i
asked this to alex smith i said nobody
ever asked you about your good leg so
let me ask you about how's your good leg
matt cause
i see sometimes it probably gives me
more problems than
you have a bionic
right leg yeah i got a terminator leg on
that side
well congrats it's a great story but
it's not done and uh i know you can't be
satisfied by just making a little cameo
against notre dame but uh yes sir
uh yes sir yeah good luck to uh to
jordan there with that competition
because i'm sure you'll be uh you'll
have your helmet on uh for every game
ready to go in but uh hey congrats mack
it's a great story and uh good luck the
rest of the season
thank you i appreciate you that's
mackenzie milton florida state
quarterback a lot of attitude on that
guy